Hello, my friends, we are here today. Listener, before you change your channel. Sorry, I was just trying to do, I thought that we had an international market. So I was like, you know, trying to say hi. But now I could do like this as well. Welcome to Smarlas, maybe I'll come here and I'll have a take one coffee. It's a wrap. Thank you.
大家好，我们今天又在这里了。听众朋友们，在你们换台之前……抱歉，我刚刚只是想……我以为我们有国际市场，所以我想打个招呼。但现在我也可以这样。欢迎来到 Smarlas，也许我会去那儿买杯咖啡。就这样，谢谢。
Or maybe I'll go see my mistress and I'll hit every cliché in the book. And welcome to a... one coffee, a cigarette, and a bag of beer, or maybe a coffee by mistress, and I'll hit every cliché in the book, and welcome to a, is an onus, Marles. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
或者也许我会去找我的情妇，然后把书里所有的陈词滥调都用上一遍。欢迎来到……一杯咖啡、一支烟和一袋啤酒，或者也许是情妇给的一杯咖啡，把书里所有的陈词滥调都用上一遍，欢迎来到，真是个荣誉，马尔斯。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. This is smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。这太聪明了。
Bless. Will, you fired up about your guest? Actually, oh my god. Wait, let me guess. It's an on Janu, and that's why you're trying to be nice and cool. Okay. A little gel in his hair. Yeah, your hair looks amazing.
太棒了。威尔，你对今天的嘉宾很兴奋吧？其实，哦天哪。等等，让我猜猜。是个安·亚努，所以你才想表现得友善又酷。好吧。头发上抹了点发胶。对，你的发型看起来棒极了。
Yeah, it's banging. I got... Is this somebody... Is your guests... Is somebody that you have a crush on? Do you have a crush on your guest? I have a major talent crush on this person, yeah. And...
对，太帅了。我有……这是某人……你的嘉宾……是你暗恋的人吗？你暗恋你的嘉宾吗？我对这个人有着极大的才华崇拜，是的。而且……
Oh, man! It's a man! And he's got a smoky laugh. Don't laugh, don't laugh. Don't laugh, your laugh is too disdainful, man. Don't laugh! Now he's fart is too distaste man don't let oh Now he's farting Oh
哦，天哪！是个男的！而且他有一种烟嗓般的笑声。别笑，别笑。别笑，你的笑声太轻蔑了，伙计。别笑！现在他放屁也太让人倒胃口了，伙计，别让……哦，现在他放屁了，哦。
No, now you guys you'll definitely get it now you guys. Oh my god First of all that's's Cargolio, Bungwater, right? Go ahead, Sean. I was trying to tell you about my birthday dinner last night. Yeah, let's hear that. Yeah, hey, happy birthday, Sean. Happy birthday, Sean.
不，现在你们……你们肯定能猜到了，伙计们。哦天哪，首先那是卡戈利奥，邦沃特，对吧？说吧，肖恩。我正想跟你说说我昨晚的生日晚餐呢。对，让我们听听。耶，嘿，生日快乐，肖恩。生日快乐，肖恩。
Thank you, thank you. Did you finish all the cupcakes, Will, and I sent you? Yes, that was incredible. I didn't finish them, but yeah. Whatever sweet treat it was. I got the second, the second I opened it, thank you, by the way. The second I opened it, I've,
谢谢，谢谢。你吃完我和威尔送你的所有纸杯蛋糕了吗？是的，太棒了。我没吃完，不过，对。不管那是什么甜点。我拿到它的那一秒，顺便说一句，谢谢。我拿到它的那一秒，我，
a port of glass, I'm giant milk and I went right into it. Okay. But the next night, so Scotty gets this, so Scotty gets this reference to, I mean, I'm sorry, referral to this restaurant that's on Billionaires Row in New York City, right? You know, on 57th. Central Park South.
倒了一大杯牛奶，直接就开吃。好吧。但第二天晚上，斯科蒂得到这个，呃，斯科蒂得到了这个推荐，我是说，抱歉，是一家位于纽约市亿万富翁街（Billionaires Row）的餐厅的推荐，对吧？你知道的，在57街。中央公园南。
Yeah. Whatever it is. It was Central Park South. Yeah, whatever it is. Right, it was Central Park South or on 57th Street. You keep going billionaires, right? Is that what they call it? Now, I never use that term. I don't know.
对。不管是什么。那是中央公园南。对，不管是什么。对，那是中央公园南或者57街。你一直在说亿万富翁，对吧？他们是这么叫的吗？不，我从来不用这个词。我不知道。
That's what I heard. I have no idea. I'm not a billionaire. But so you have to get a reservation. The conversation's over. Yeah. You have to get a reservation, right? So Scotty asks this person who asked this question.
我听说是这样的。我完全不知道。我又不是亿万富翁。但你得预订。谈话结束了。对。你必须预订，对吧？所以斯科蒂问了这个提问的人。
We want you to go to the Russian T-Rome. That's right above it, actually. Yeah. So the, uh, so we go into this building who asked this person. Who would you go to the Russian T-Rome? That's right above it, actually. Yeah. So we go into this building. It's crazy. It's got all the security. We're scared to walk in. And we walk in.
我们想让你去俄罗斯茶室（Russian Tea Room）。其实就在它正上方。对。所以，呃，所以我们走进这栋大楼，是谁问的这个人？你会去俄罗斯茶室吗？其实就在它正上方。对。所以我们走进这栋大楼。太疯狂了。到处都是安保。我们走进去时都吓坏了。然后我们走进去。
We're like, hey, I have a reservation. And it's on the 100th floor. Yeah. 100th floor. Oh, Will, I think I sent you the video. Yeah, you did. That's why I keep going. Yeah, I know.
我们就像，嘿，我预订了。而且它在100层。对。100层。哦，威尔，我想我给你发过视频了。对，你发过。所以我才一直说。对，我知道。
Oh, gosh. Hang on a sec. Let me check. See., it must be my trash. It was really late. Jay, it was really late. I didn't want to disturb you. Oh, wait, I'll show you. You should have looked them. They looked like a couple of dudes are in from Scenectady. You know what I mean? Like, they were so excited to be there. Look at the heights of this. Wait, does this restaurant rotate slowly? No, look at this, Jay. Look at this. Look at this. That's Scotty.
哦，天哪。等一下。让我查查。看，一定在我的废件箱里。真的很晚了，杰伊，真的很晚了。我不想打扰你。哦，等等，我给你看。你应该看看他们。他们看起来就像两个从斯克内克塔迪来的家伙。你知道我的意思吗？就像，他们能去那里兴奋得不得了。看看这个高度。等等，这餐厅会慢慢旋转吗？不，看这个，杰伊。看这个。看这个。那是斯科蒂。
And that's you. By the way, they just look like animated LinkedIn profiles. Look at that. Both you guys. So it is rotating. No, the camera's rotating. Oh, isn't that wild? That view.
那是你。顺便说一句，他们看起来就像会动的领英（LinkedIn）个人主页。看看这个。你们俩。所以它确实在转。不，是摄像机在转。哦，不是很疯狂吗？那个风景。
It's what I never want to do it again though, because it was heights. I couldn't go. So guess what? So I said to Sean, I talked to Sean before he left, and he goes, he's telling me he was going, and I said, are you scared? He's like, yeah, I'm scared.
不过我再也不想去了，因为太高了。我受不了。所以你猜怎么着？我跟肖恩谈过，在他离开之前我跟他聊过，他说他要去，我问他，你害怕吗？他说，对，我害怕。
I mean, well, you were scared. I was so scared. I was really scared. I don't need to do that. Are you guys okay with that? I'm not okay with that. I don't want to be up that high. I don't need it.
我是说，好吧，你当时确实很害怕。我太害怕了。我真的吓坏了。我可不想再去了。你们能接受这个吗？我可接受不了。我不想去那么高的地方。我不需要。
I don't really. The food was good though. Yeah. But it's kind of good for weight loss, right? You go up there, you lose your appetite. You don't really want to eat a bunch. Yeah, love it. Is that why the weight loss, right? You go up there, you lose your appetite, you don't really want to eat a bunch. Yeah, love it. Is that why is it the restaurants for skinny folk?
我真的不需要。不过菜挺好吃的。对。但这对减肥挺有帮助的，对吧？你上去，食欲就没了。你根本不想吃太多。对，太棒了。这就是减肥的原因吗？你上去，食欲就没了，你根本不想吃太多。对，太棒了。这是专为瘦子开的餐厅吗？
Yeah. By the way, there's only five tables, not even kidding. There we go. Because it's a restaurant for the residences. I can clearly spit tag on my microphone at the loop around to weight loss. Guys, this body is no fluke. Okay, I've told you before. Sure, isn't. That's what makes it worse is that it's by design. Hey, you know what's great
对。顺便说一句，只有五张桌子，真没开玩笑。就是这样。因为它是住宅区的餐厅。我肯定有唾沫星子喷到麦克风上了，然后又绕回了减肥话题。伙计们，我这身材可不是侥幸，好吗？我以前就跟你说过。确实不是。更糟糕的是，这是精心设计出来的。嘿，你知道什么是精心设计的吗？
by design? Oh, here it comes a nice segue into it. But it turns out that it's really organic is a career that is just full of incredible performances, of varying sizes and characters and the grease, the things and things. Somebody who started Sean, you will enjoy, because we know you love the theater, we know you're on Broadway, still currently.
哦，漂亮的过渡要来了。但事实证明，这真的很自然，这是一个充满惊人表演的职业，有着各种不同规模的角色、油脂、各种事物。肖恩会喜欢的那种，开始于……因为我们知道你热爱戏剧，我们知道你现在还在百老汇演出。
Like the Alaska theater. Tony Award winning, hold for. Plot in Oscar. Tony Award, I love you. Is that what's called? For Good Night to Basko, the story of hot sauce. But that good night Oscar. And so this person, you're going to have, you're going to be able to get some great theater
就像阿拉斯加剧院。托尼奖得主，稍等。奥斯卡奖。托尼奖，我爱你。是这么叫的吗？为了《晚安，奥斯卡》，关于辣酱的故事。但那是《晚安，奥斯卡》。所以这个人，你将能从他身上挖出一些精彩的戏剧故事。
stories out of because he started in the theater. Not only he just started in the theater, he also ended up starting a theater. And which he went back to and performed for, you know, 40 years or more in this theater group, a very well-known theater group. He did a lot of incredible performances. He's then gone on to do so many iconic roles over the years. He's made 147 feature films. No. He's been in some of my favorite feature films, some of my favorite performances of all time. He's been nominated for four Academy Awards and Golden Globes and Sags and all the other stuff.
因为他是从戏剧起家的。不仅是从戏剧起家，他最后还创立了一个剧院。他回到那里并表演了，你知道，在这个剧团里演出长达40年或更久，一个非常著名的剧团。他有过许多精彩的表演。这些年来，他接着出演了许多标志性的角色。他拍过147部长片。不。他演过我最喜欢的一些长片，我心目中历来最精彩的一些表演。他曾四次获得奥斯卡金像奖提名，还有金球奖、美国演员工会奖以及其他各种奖项。
But for me, apart from his incredible performances in some of my favorite films, Like To Live in Dianna L.A. or Platoon, he was also Bobby Perou, maybe my favorite character, who I went as for Halloween once. Guys, it's Willem DeFoe. No way. That's a booking.
但对我来说，除了他在我最喜欢的几部电影中的精彩表演，比如《活在洛杉矶》或《野战排》，他还是鲍比·佩鲁（Bobby Peru），可能是我最喜欢的角色，我万圣节时还扮过他呢。伙计们，是威廉·达福（Willem Dafoe）。没门。这通告接得。
No way. Good morning. Oh, God. Willem DeFoe. Wow. I almost pulled the thing off the little camera. Every time you said, well, I reach for the camera. Oh, my goodness.
不可能。早安。哦，天哪。威廉·达福。哇。我差把小摄像机上的东西扯下来了。每次你说“威廉”的时候，我都去抓摄像机。哦，天哪。
He knows how to respond to a cue? Yes. Yeah. What a pleasure to a cue. Yeah, well, yeah. What a pleasure to meet you. Hi, everybody. Thank you. Yeah, it's so nice to meet you. Tell me a crushed thing, but thanks. Oh, well, it's such a, it's such a thrill to meet you.
他知道怎么接话？对。对。能接上话太荣幸了。对，好吧，对。很高兴见到你。大家好。谢谢。对，很高兴见到你。说我是被崇拜的对象什么的，不过谢谢。哦，好吧，这真是……这真是太让人激动了。
And I did say it. So I want to kind of get it out of the way. I did in the 19, the year that Wilde and Hart came out, I went like a month later, I went as Bobby Peruv for to a Halloween party. And I bought some vampire teeth at a store down on Eight Street. And I took a lighter or something. I mean, I'm like flat and dark and I put them in. And I wore a Bolo tie.
我确实说过了。所以我只想把它抛在脑后。19……《野外的心》（Wild at Heart）上映的那一年，大约一个月后，我去参加一个万圣节派对，扮成了鲍比·佩鲁。我在第八街的一家店里买了一些吸血鬼牙齿。我用打火机什么的……我的意思是，我把它们弄扁、弄黑然后戴上。我还戴了一条波洛领带（Bolo tie）。
And I won't say what he was, what he kept saying. What were you kept saying like catchphrase? Yeah, it's catchphrase, but he kept saying is like, what is he talking about? You're pussy or something. I don't know, it was terrible. It was something terrible. So that's when you were just barking all night?
我不会说他当时在说什么。你一直挂在嘴边的是什么？口头禅吗？对，是口头禅，但他一直说的是，他在说什么啊？你的小穴什么的。我不知道，太糟糕了。是一些很糟糕的话。所以那就是你整晚都在狂吠的时候？
Yeah, I mean, I met a lot of friends as you're gonna manage. Sure, yeah. And let's go see if you guys know that. So I want to get that out of the way. But Willem Dafoe, what a thrill to meet you, man. Great. Thanks. So, yeah.
对，我的意思是，正如你所料，我结识了很多朋友。当然，是的。让我们看看你们知不知道那个。所以我想把这个抛开。但是威廉·达福，见到你真是太激动了，伙计。太棒了。谢谢。所以，是的。
Nice to be here. We have no questions. We have no questions. Okay, ciao. No, we do. So, it's true, right? I was right in the intro, Willem, that you started. Let's start at the beginning.
很高兴来到这里。我们没有问题。我们没有问题。好吧，再见。不，我们有。所以，这是真的，对吧？我在开场白里说得没错，威廉，你是一开始……让我们从头说起。
You started in the theater. I know that you're from Wisconsin and then you moved to New York and you got a meeting. Well, you're doing sort of theater in Wisconsin, Milwaukee, in some avant-garde theater, and then you moved to New York and started doing that there. Am I right in that? That's right. That's right. I still do theater, but last because for many years, I had a company, so every day I was going into work, you know, the way, you know, regular people do. Yeah.
你从戏剧起家。我知道你来自威斯康星州，然后你搬到了纽约，然后你有个会议……好吧，你在威斯康星州密尔沃基做过某种前卫戏剧，然后你搬到纽约并在那里开始做这个。我没记错吧？没错。没错。我仍然在做戏剧，但现在少了，因为很多年里，我有自己的公司，所以每天我都要去上班，你知道的，就像正常人那样。是的。
You know, really every day that I was not on a movie set, I was either at the theater working or we were on tour. It was really a whole life. One thing that's worth mentioning, yeah, I did start doing theater in Milwaukee with a small group called Theader X. But then when I moved to New York because I had ants in my pants and ambition. And also it was a time where a lot of things were happening in New York. And I felt like I wanted to be there, particularly the music scene, not that I'm a musician.
你知道，真的，只要我不在电影片场，我要么在剧院工作，要么就在巡演。这真的是一种完整的生活。有一点值得一提，是的，我确实开始在密尔沃基与一个名为“Theater X”的小团体一起做戏剧。但后来当我搬到纽约时，因为我屁股坐不住、满怀雄心壮志。而且当时纽约发生了很多事情。我觉得我想去那里，特别是音乐界，虽然我不是音乐家。
But it felt like stuff was going on. So I went there, but I think it's fun to tell you that I really intended to be conventional theater actor, audition and all that. But that's what year was this? Well, initially I went in 75, but then this company in Milwaukee that had seen me in my brief period at school called me back to going tour with them. I did work with them for a couple of years.
但我觉得那里很有活力。所以我去了，但我认为有趣的是，我最初是想成为一个传统的戏剧演员，去试镜诸如此类的。但那是哪一年？嗯，我最初是在75年去的，但后来密尔沃基的那家公司在学校的短暂期间看过我的表演，又把我叫回去和他们一起巡演。我和他们一起工作了几年。
They were called Theater X. It was a company run, small company. We did original work, which was very cool. We toured mostly internationally, not so much in the States. And, yeah, that's what I did for the past. Just doing a bunch of different plays. Or, we were making plays, you know, generally. Right, original.
他们叫 Theater X。那是一个公司运营的小型公司。我们做原创作品，非常酷。我们主要在国际上巡演，在美国国内倒是不多。而且，是的，这就是我过去所做的。只是做一堆不同的戏剧。或者说，我们在创作戏剧，你知道的，通常是这样。没错，原创。
We had a writer that worked with us. And occasionally we'd do plays, but they were kind of unconventional. Where were you going internationally? You just take your merry band of... Mostly Germany and Holland at the time. There was a very good place called the Mickery in Amsterdam. And it was really where I got my education because they brought in theater.
我们有一个和我们合作的编剧。偶尔我们也演剧本，但它们有点非传统。你们当时去国际上哪些地方？你们就带着你们快乐的小队伍……当时主要是德国和荷兰。阿姆斯特丹有一个非常棒的地方叫 The Mickery。那真是我受教育的地方，因为他们引进了戏剧。
They had lots of money. And they brought theater from all over the world. And when I was there, I'd see things, you know, from Japan, I'd see things from Africa. I'd see a lot of the great Peter Brook. I'd see lots of great theater companies from Europe. Peter Brook, who's sort of, you know, with like one of the Godfrey, if you guys don't know,
他们有充足的资金。他们从世界各地引进戏剧。我在那里的时候，会看到来自日本的东西，看到来自非洲的东西。我会看很多伟大的彼得·布鲁克（Peter Brook）的作品。我会看到许多来自欧洲的伟大剧团。彼得·布鲁克，他有点像……如果你不知道的话，他就像是……
one of the Godfathers of sort of avant-garde theater and he's just incredible. And of course, Amsterdam may beda maybe great place because everybody's all knocked out on grass, you know what I mean. Yeah. You do it all, so it's crazy. But so everyone's doing these plays in English, obviously, even though they're from Germany or Africa or... No, not necessarily.
某种前卫戏剧教父级别的人物，他简直太棒了。当然，阿姆斯特丹也许是个好地方，因为每个人都抽大麻抽得神魂颠倒，你知道我的意思吗？是的。你什么都做，所以这很疯狂。但是每个人都在用英语演这些戏，显然是的，尽管他们来自德国或非洲……不一定。
Not necessarily. Because it's also the kind of... They're the kind of performances in place that don't necessarily lean too heavily on the playwright. Not always, sometimes yes. But it's more about the production. Because it's a theater that is more based on other elements, not just on the playwright and on conventional elements. But what I was gonna say before, and you guys are so fast, I'm a little slow,
不一定。因为这也是那种……它们是那种不一定过分依赖剧作家的表演和戏剧。不总是这样，有时是。但这更多是关于制作本身的。因为这种戏剧更多地基于其他元素，而不仅仅是剧作家和传统元素。但我想说的是，而且你们反应太快了，我有点慢，
when I moved to New York, I really intended to be like a guy or a dish name and go to Broadway and that kind of thing. But I just found myself going downtown, and going to loft performances and just getting really attracted to these people that were working down there. And I felt like as a kid from Wisconsin,
当我搬到纽约时，我真的打算成为那种去试镜、去百老汇之类的地方的人。但我发现自己总是去市中心，去阁楼演出，并真正被那些在那里工作的人所吸引。我觉得作为一个来自威斯康星州的孩子，
it really transformed me. You know, it really made me see theater in a new way and made me see performing in a new way. And that was really exciting. We're in Wisconsin. My sister lives in Wisconsin. Is she doing okay? She's doing okay.
这真的改变了我。你知道，它真的让我以一种新的方式看待戏剧，以一种新的方式看待表演，这真的很令人兴奋。我们在威斯康星州。我姐姐住在威斯康星州。她过得还好吗？她过得挺好的。
Thanks. I just want to know if you grew up there anywhere close to her. I grew up in Appleton, Wisconsin. She lived for a long time in white water, but she's not there in water. There's a university there. Yeah, that's where her husband worked.
谢谢。我只是想知道你成长的地方离她近不近。我在威斯康星州的阿普leton长大的。她曾在怀特沃特（White Water）住了很长时间，但她现在不在怀特沃特了。那里有一所大学。对，那是她丈夫工作的地方。
As a, yeah, that's usually the reason someone's in university there. Yeah, that's where her husband worked as a... Okay. That's usually the reason someone's in white water. And white water. We have a big... And this is not even a bit, well, this is... We have a huge following in Wisconsin. We're like the number one podcast in Wisconsin. So it's quite a trophy.
作为一个……对，那通常是某人在那里上大学的原因。对，那是她丈夫工作的地方，作为一个……好吧。那通常是某人在怀特沃特的原因。在怀特沃特。我们有一个庞大的……而且这甚至不是个梗，好吧，这是……我们在威斯康星州拥有庞大的粉丝群体。我们就像是威斯康星州排名第一播客。所以这算是一个很大的荣誉。
It's actually a true story. It sounds like a weird thing to say, but it's kind of true. So Willem, your choices in style and talent and everything is so always fresh and surprising and could even say avant-garde. Do you think it started there with what sounds like a very atypical theater scene that you've been able to carry on and and kind of um you know we're the beneficiaries of that you always seem to take a very fresh take on any of the characters that you play and you and you pull it off. Thank you.
这其实是个真实的故事。听起来有点奇怪，但差不多是真的。所以，威廉，你在风格、才华和各个方面的选择总是那么清新、令人惊叹，甚至可以说是前卫的。你认为这是从那里开始的吗？那种听起来非常非传统的戏剧界，让你能够将其延续下来，并且……你知道的，我们是这其中的受益者，你对你扮演的任何角色总是采取一种非常清新的视角，而且你总是能成功驾驭。谢谢。
Thank you. Start back from back then? Yeah you must have I mean because really performing in the theater really formed my taste, my nose, the things I was interested in. So that definitely, you know, is shaped to I.M. as a performer and what my appetites were. But always when people, quite frankly, I feel flattered when people say, oh, you choose well or you choose interesting things. That sounds good, but I always maintain that projects find you and you find projects. It's not like it's not in my control.
谢谢。从那个时候开始的吗？是的，你肯定……我是说，因为在剧院里的表演确实塑造了我的品味、我的直觉、我感兴趣的事物。所以这绝对塑造了我作为一个表演者的身份以及我的胃口。但坦率地说，每当人们说“哦，你选得很棒”或“你选的东西很有趣”时，我总是感到受宠若惊。听起来不错，但我一直坚持认为，是项目找到了你，你找到了项目。这不是……这不是我能控制的。
True, but when you are given a script that has a Willem Dafoe character in it, which is to say something that's not simple. You, and these are not auditions at this point, you're showing up on set with this incredibly gifted take on something. What is that process like for you? Is there an anxiety that you have still to this day about,
确实，但当你拿到一个带有威廉·达福式角色的剧本时——也就是说这不是一个简单的角色——而且这个时候已经不是试镜了，你带着对某种事物的极其天才的理解出现在片场。对你来说，那个过程是怎样的？你至今是否仍会感到焦虑？
oh my gosh, is the first time they're gonna see this big swing I'm taking. Now, I'm gonna pull it off, but they gotta hang in there with me before they tell me not to do it and trust that I can get there and deliver it in full. Do you think about that stuff? I don't try to do that.
哦天哪，这是他们第一次看到我做出这么大的突破吗？现在，我能成功驾驭吗，但在他们告诉我不要这么做之前，他们必须陪我一起坚持，并相信我能做到并完美呈现。你会想这些事情吗？我尽量不去想这些。
You don't? No, I try not to think about myself. I hide behind other people. Yeah, yeah. Like directors are very important for me. And I feel like at least whether it's true or not, I trick myself to saying, I'm just this guy that's going to go there and help this person realize what they're doing. And it's, I never have like, I never have ideas, I go to a place, you know, I prepare and I have something up my sleeve and I have certain kind of tendencies of taste and things I'm attracted to. But really,
真的吗？不，我尽量不把注意力放在自己身上。我藏在其他人身后。对，对。比如导演对我很重要。我觉得，不管是不是真的，我都在心里说服自己：我只是个去那里帮助这个人实现他们想法的家伙。而且，我从来没有……我从来没有什么宏大的想法，我到一个地方，你知道，我做准备，我留有一手，我有某种口味的倾向和被吸引的事物。但实际上，
I go there and I see what's there and then I try to have an adventure. And usually, as far as self-consciousness about how am I doing or my choices or this is a risk or this is not a risk or what are they going to think of this. I really trick myself into not thinking about those things. Well, I read this interview from you when you're younger talking about this very thing, about your relationship to the audience or like going for something and like going for a result or we're inhabiting a role, all these kinds of ideas that you're talking about.
我去那里，看看那里有什么，然后我试着去经历一场冒险。通常，至于对“我表现得怎么样”、“我的选择”、“这是一个冒险还是不是一个冒险”或者“他们会怎么看这个”的自我意识，我真的在心理上说服自己不去想这些事情。好吧，我读过你年轻时的一次采访，谈到正是这件事，关于你与观众的关系，或者说去争取某种结果，或者说融入一个角色，你谈到了所有这些你正在谈论的想法。
And you talked about this idea that, well, first of all, one of my favorite quotes that I found when I was reading about you, which is whenever you talk to actors and they've done special preparation, whether it's putting on lots of weight or hanging out with junkies or being a junkie, they go on and on about it
你谈到了这样一个想法——首先，当我阅读关于你的资料时，我发现了我最喜欢的一句话之一，那就是每当你和演员谈论他们的特殊准备时，无论是增肥很多，还是跟瘾君子厮混，或者自己就是个瘾君子，他们都会滔滔不绝地谈论这些，
and it makes good copy for people magazine and all that, and people like the irritant, but inevitably it gets self-satisfying and precious. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That was, yeah. Which made me laugh, because I was kind of with you on that. But what struck me was,
这给《人物》杂志（People magazine）和其他媒体提供了很好的素材，人们也喜欢这种噱头，但不可避免地，这会变得自我满足和矫揉造作。对，对，对。那是，是的。这让我笑了，因为我在某种程度上也同意你的看法。但令我震惊的是，
and this kind of goes to Jason, I think what you were getting at, which is like, you said that you don't inhabit a role. You are for moments while you're doing the role, taking the character through the sort of, within the context of what you've been giving the character is gonna do in the scene, you do that. But it's not you, is that kind of right?
这有点符合杰伊的意思，我想你刚才要表达的是，你说你不会完全融入一个角色。在扮演角色的那几分钟里，你是把这个角色带过……在剧本赋予这个角色的场景上下文范围内，你这么做了。但这并不是你，是这样吗？
Well, it's all me because it's not anybody else. But, you know, you kind of figure where all people, we have the capacity to be all people. But I don't like this idea of choices or interpretation. I like the idea of doing actions, like an athlete. And when you give yourself to those actions, it puts you in a place where there's a kind of logic. And if the world is built correct, and if you enter the world in a correct way,
嗯，这全部都是我，因为这不是其他人。但是，你知道，你会弄清楚我们所有人都是人类，我们有成为所有人的潜质。但我并不喜欢这种“选择”或“诠释”的概念。我喜欢“采取行动”的概念，就像运动员一样。当你把自己交托给这些行动时，它会把你带到一个存在某种逻辑的地方。如果这个世界的构建是正确的，如果你以正确的方式进入这个世界，
and aren't too obsessed about saying something, but being there, then I think you learn stuff. You have a special concentration and a special relationship to what's going on in that room. The trick I think always is, yes, you've got to prepare something, but the people that really turn me on when I'm working with them is people that work with what's there. They are pointing to stuff outside. They aren't thinking about the audience outside.
并且不过于沉迷于想要表达什么，而是专注于“存在”于那里，那么我认为你会学到东西。你会有一种特殊的专注力，以及与那个房间里正在发生的事情建立一种特殊的联系。我认为其中的诀窍始终是：是的，你必须准备一些东西，但当我与那些真正让我兴奋的人合作时，他们是利用现有的东西进行创作。他们指的是外面的东西。他们没有去想外面的观众。
They aren't sending messages. audience, I'll say. They aren't sending messages. They aren't, you know, nothing exists. The world drops away. And this is your life. If you can get behind that, then you're actually free. I was going to say kind of actually again to what Jason was saying was about taking the big swing. I guess you feel free if you're not worried about, because I, yeah, I agree, you're not, if you're not worried, if you're not encumbered by that thought of taking a big swing, because in your mind, there is no swing. You're just being in the moment, right? Yeah.
他们没有在发送信息。我是说，观众。他们没有在发送信息。他们没有……你知道的，什么都不存在。世界消失了。这就是你的生活。如果你能克服这一点，那么你实际上就自由了。我本来想说的是，其实还是呼应杰伊刚才说的，关于做出大的突破。我想如果你不担心，如果你不被那种“做出大突破”的想法所拖累，你就会感到自由，因为在你的脑海里，根本没有什么突破。你只是活在当下，对吧？是的。
That's one way to think about it. You know, it's, it's funny. Everybody's different. Yeah. And, you know, you touch different buttons and you're interested in different things. I like all kinds of performances So when I say this stuff it's not a right way to be I'm trying to figure out what makes me tick in this context You know, so I'm just trying on some stuff for size not to create a method, but really to think about
这是一种思考方式。你知道，这很有趣。每个人都是不同的。而且，你知道，你会触及不同的按钮，对不同的事物感兴趣。我喜欢各种各样的表演。所以当我这么说时，并不是说有一种正确的方式。我只是想弄清楚在这个语境下是什么在驱使我，你知道的。所以我只是试穿一些东西看看合不合适，不是为了创造某种方法，而是真正去思考
What the consistent things are when I enter a movie or I do a play or something or what performing is about for me. Have you ever showed up on a set to all of this point? Have you ever showed up with taking a swing? All you did all this prep and the first take happens and the director goes, can't talk to you for a minute. And uh, far less. Well, yeah, I was going to say on that, do you, uh, and, and I obviously met no disrespect with saying big swings, but like, there are only a few actors. You are one of those few that can take a swing that is something we've never seen before or imagined
当我进入一部电影或演出一幕戏时，什么是恒定不变的东西，或者说表演对我来说意味着什么。到目前为止，你有没有在片场出现过这样的情况：你做出了一个突破，你做了所有的准备，第一条拍完后，导演说，能跟你谈一分钟吗？远没有那么多。好吧，我本来想问那个，你是否……而且，我显然绝无不尊重“大突破”这个词的意思，但是——只有少数演员。你是那少数几个能够做出我们从未见过或想象过的突破，并且完美执行的演员之一。你在排练时会和导演交谈，至少进行某种对话，或者甚至是创造性的协商，以确保你对该角色的特定诠释能够融入导演为该电影制定的许多其他计划中——比如色调、其他演员的表现，
and completely executed flawlessly. Do you have conversations with the director in rehearsals where at least they get some sort of a conversation or maybe even a creative negotiation to make sure that that particular take on the character fits into the other many, many plans that a director has for that film as far as tone goes, what the other actors are gonna be doing,
以及它在创意上的整体轮廓，并在你到达片场之前确保你与这些保持一致？是的，你提出了一个让我觉得很有趣的话题，而且你不需要进行那些交谈。你凭直觉就能感受到，但我真的对……你提出了一个让我觉得很有趣的话题。而且你知道，你不需要进行那些交谈。你凭直觉就能感受到。但我真的被……所震撼，
what the shape of it creatively is going to be, and make sure you're in line with that before you get on the set. Yeah, you bring up something interesting to me, and you don't have those conversations. You kind of intuit it, but I'm really struck by, bring up something interesting to me. And you know, you don't have those conversations. You kind of intuit it. But I'm really struck by, you know,
拍电影或演戏的美妙之处在于，每一次都是不同的。所以这非常重要。你工作的一部分就是环顾四周，看看谁在那里，看看他们是如何工作的，看看他们的倾向是什么，看看这个世界是什么样的，然后融入其中。哦，那太棒了。是的。
the beauty of making movies or doing places every time it's different. So it's very important. Part of your job is to look around, see who's there, see how they work, see what their tendencies are, see what the world is, and fold in. Oh, that's wonderful. Yeah.
很多人甚至在看到其他人之前就决定了他们将如何扮演这个角色，而你的可塑性是如此惊人。这至少是理论上的，也许我并非如此。但是，威廉，你有没有过那种时候？你有没有进来然后觉得，好吧，等等——就像杰伊刚才说的，我有这个想法进来，然后你觉得，好吧，等等——就像杰伊刚才说的，我有这个想法进来，然后你觉得，
So many people decide how they're gonna do the part before they even see what everyone else is, and the fact that you're malleable is, that's amazing. That's the theory anyway, maybe I'm not. But Willem, do you ever kind of do that? Do you ever come in and then go like, okay, so wait, so I had like Jason was saying, like I have this idea come in, and then you go like, okay, so wait, so I had like, Jason was saying, like, I have this idea come in and then you go like,
哦，每个人都在这里，好吧，也许我要稍微抛弃一点。现在我要稍微换个方向，就像在当下那样。绝对的，是的，这很酷。但我来的时候不会带着太多的想法。我不相信那个。不，不，真的，听着，有时你读剧本，
oh, everybody's kind of here like, okay, well, maybe I'm gonna kind of shed a little bit of that. Now I'm gonna kind of move it this way, like in the moment. Absolutely, yeah, that's cool. But I don't come with too many ideas. I don't believe that. No, no, really, listen, sometimes you read a script
有时你会说，哇，我对这个有特殊的见解。我想为此而在场。或者这离我很远。我得做点研究。我得经历一些事情，你知道的，才能融入这个世界。这两者都很好。我们马上回来。
and sometimes you say, wow, I have special information on this. I want to be there for this. Or this is so far away from me. I got to do some research. I got to go through something to, you know, be in this world. And both are good. Yeah. We'll be right back.
Smartless 听众由 BetterHelp 赞助。你知道，在我们所有人的生活中，总有时会遇到一些我们不知道该如何处理的事情，让我们有点不知所措，不知道该怎么熬过去。你是否曾发现，就在你试图入睡时，你的大脑突然喋喋不休地停不下来？
Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, there are times in all of our lives when we've had things pop up that we don't know how to deal with. And it's left us kind of wondering how we're gonna get through it. Do you ever find that just as you're trying to fall asleep, your brain suddenly won't stop talking?
你的思绪是否在临睡前或其他不合时宜的时刻开始狂飙？好吧，事实证明，让这些狂飙的思绪平静下来的一个好方法就是把它们说出来。治疗为你提供了一个这样做的地方。这样你就可以摆脱消极的思维循环，找到一些心理和情感上的平静。如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，
Do your thoughts start racing right before bed or at other in opportune moments? Well, it turns out one great way to make those racing thoughts go ways to talk them through. Therapy gives you a place to do that. So you can get out of your negative thought cycles and find some mental and emotional peace. If you're thinking of starting therapy,
不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在提供便利、灵活并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与获得执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。
give better help, a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists at any time for no additional charge.
因为那些事情确实会出现。多年来，我有过几次这样的时刻，感觉有太多的事情同时发生。有太多的事情让人觉得难以承受，我不知道自己该如何应对。也许是因为我年纪够大了，但你知道，我觉得即使我更年轻，我也会有同样的风想法，那就是：我该怎么处理这个？因为我感到很不舒服。我能感觉到，如果我感到不舒服，
Because that stuff does come up. I've had over the years a few moments where it just felt like there were too many moving pieces. There were too many things that felt overwhelming and I wasn't sure how I was supposed to react to them. And maybe because I was old enough, but you know, I think even if I were younger, I would have had the same thought, which was like, what do I do about this? Because I don't feel comfortable. And I can tell for me, if I don't feel comfortable,
我需要去找个人谈谈。我非常感激自己能有机会，或者仅仅是——我不知道——我主动去和专业人士谈了谈，因为这完全改变了……我主动去和专业人士谈了谈，因为它完全改变了我看待生活中无论发生什么事情的方式。我可以离开时心想：你知道吗？我感觉思路更清晰了，我没有感到
that I need to go and talk to somebody about it. And I'm really grateful that I was able to have the opportunity, or just the, I don't know, that I took the initiative to go and talk to a professional about it, because it completely changed the, that I took the initiative to go and talk to a professional about it, because it completely changed the way that I looked at whatever was going on in my life. And I could walk away thinking, you know what? I feel more clear, and I don't feel
像开始治疗前那样情绪失控。而且，你知道，对我来说，这很管用。每当我去找专业人士倾诉时，我都感觉好多了，所有那些曾经觉得巨大且无法逾越的事情都被拉回到了一个恰当的比例。通过 BetterHelp 让你的思绪休息一下。今天就访问 betterhelp.com/smartless，首月即可享受 9 折优惠。网址是 betterhelp（即 H-E-L-p）点 com 斜杠 smartless。
as emotionally kind of spun out as I did right before I started the session. And, you know, for me, it works. Anytime I've gone and talked to a professional, I've just felt so much better and all those things that felt so huge and insurmountable kind of got brought back into a right-size place. Get a break from your thoughts with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help, H-E-L-p dot com slash smartless.
Smartless 的听众们，我们得到了 FanDuel 的支持。在这个 NFL 赛季，通过 FanDuel（美国第一大体育博彩公司）迅速采取行动。现在，新客户只要下注 5 美元，即可保证获得 200 美元的奖金投注。下注 5 美元即可保证获得 200 美元的奖金投注。无论输赢，都有 200 美元的奖金投注。如果你一直在考虑加入 FanDuel，现在正是加入的最佳时机。
Smartless listener, we are supported by FanDuel. Snap into action this NFL season with FanDuel America's number one sports book. Right now, new customers get $200 in bonus bets guaranteed when you place a $5 bet. That's $200 in bonus bets guaranteed when you place a $5 bet. That's $200 in bonus bets winner lose. If you've been thinking about joining a fan duel, there's no better time to get in on the action.
这款应用程序易于使用。有广泛的投注选择，包括让分盘、球员道具、大小盘等等。你知道吗，肖恩，顺便说一句，如果他能对音乐剧下注，比如服装或布景设计的赔率，他一定会觉得很有趣。所以，我不知道，我认为这将是肖恩会喜欢的事情。我很想看他尝试设定赔率，我也很想看他为此下注。所以这是我会去研究的事情。你知道，对我来说，我是 FanDuel 的粉丝，我也是粉丝（fans）的粉丝。
The app is easy to use. There's a wide range of betting options, including spreads, player props, overunders, and more. You know, Sean, by the way, would have a lot of fun if he could bet on musicals, you know, odds against maybe costumes or set design. So I don't know, I think that that would be something that Sean would enjoy. I'd love to see him actually try to set up the odds and I'd love to see him bet on that. So that's something that I am going to look into. You know, for me, I'm a fan of duels and I'm also a fan of fans.
我喜欢粉丝。我喜欢见粉丝。我喜欢从风扇（fan）那里得到凉爽的微风。所以，对我来说，这真的很有意义。如果我能拥有“双重风扇”（dual fans），也就是两个风扇，那就更好了。而且我也曾去过一场我参与的决斗（duel），并且我扇风（fanned off）了
I love a fan. I love meeting a fan. I like getting a cool breeze from a fan. So, you know, for me, this really adds up. And if I can have dual fans as in two fans, then even better. And I've also been known to go to a duel that I was involved with, and I fanned off
决斗中的双方参与者。所以对多我来说，这真的是多管齐下。因此，请访问 fanduel.com/smartless 并开启 NFL 赛季。FanDuel 是 NFL 的官方合作伙伴，21岁以上且有除外条款适用，完整免责声明请参阅节目说明。
both participants in the duel. So really, it's just like multi-pronged for me. So visit fandool.com slash smartless and kick off the NFL season. Fan-dual official partner of the NFL, 21 plus exclusion supply, C show notes for full disclaimer. partner of the NFL, 21-plus exclusion supply, C-Show notes for full disclaimer. SmartLess is supported by Zip Recruiter.
SmartLess 得到了 ZipRecruiter 的支持。你知道吗？如果你是一个正在招聘的雇主，平均每次招聘的成本是 4,700 美元。如果你在每个新员工身上投资了那么多钱，你就希望万无一失。那么，找到最适合你岗位的优秀人才的最有效方法是什么？ZipRecruiter。自己来看看吧。现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com/smartless 上免费试用，体验 ZipRecruiter 为招聘带来的价值。
Did you know that? If you're an employer who's hiring, the average cost per hire is $4,700. If you're investing that much money into each new hire, you want to get it right. So, what's the most effective way to find the best people for your roles? Zip Recruiter. See for yourself. Right now, you can try it for free at ziprecruiter.com slash smartless and experience the value ziprecruiter brings to hiring.
ZipRecruiter 让你先试后买。试用 ZipRecruiter 是免费的。你可以免费发布职位，从而亲自体验 ZipRecruiter 在帮助你招聘方面的效率。很简单。ZipRecruiter 助你轻松搞定招聘。在 ZipRecruiter 上发布职位的雇主中，有五分之四在第一天内就获得了优质候选人。
Zip Recruiter lets you try before you commit. There's no cost to try Zipper Cruder. You can post jobs for free, so you can see for yourself how effective Zipper Cruder is at helping you hire. It's simple. Zipper Cruder helps you get hiring right. Four out of five employers who post on Zipper Cruder get a quality candidate within the first day.
亲自来看看吧。前往这个专属网址免费试用 ZipRecruiter，在第一天内获得优质候选人，亲自体验吧。前往这个专属网址，在购买前免费试用 ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再次强调，网址是 zipracruder.com/SMARTLESS，ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。好了，回到节目中。
See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zipper Cruder, get a quality candidate within the first day, see for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zipper Cruder for free before you commit. Zipper Cruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's zipracruder.com slash SMA. RTL, ESS, Zipper Cruder, this smartest way to hire. All right, back to the show.
我有个问题想问杰伊。作为一名导演，你有没有遇到过这种情况，我们刚才讨论的？有人——你就是那个人，导演说，能跟你谈一分钟吗？如果你表现得很棒。听着，我们在考虑……比如你有没有过这种经历，你是怎么处理的？是的，这……嗯，我的意思是，我相信我们都经历过
I have a question for Jason. Have you ever been in a situation as a director where we're talking about this? Where somebody where you're the person, you're the director is like, can I talk to you for a minute? If you're doing great. Listen, we are thinking about maybe, like have you ever had that experience and what do you do about that? Yeah, it's, well, I mean, I'm sure we've all been
这些对话，其中涉及一种微妙的色调对话，因为没有绝对的坏，你知道的，只是有不同的风格，你知道的，你可以拍一出梅尔·布鲁克斯（Mel Brooks）类型的喜剧，或者你可以拍一出伍迪·艾伦（Woody Allen）类型的喜剧。它们的色调非常、非常不同。有些演员，也许他们是日薪演员，
part of these conversations where there's sort of a delicate tonal conversation because there is no bad, you know, but there are just different flavors, you know, you can have like a Mel Brooks type of comedy or you can have like a Woody Allen type of comedy. They're both tonally very, very different. And some actors, maybe their day players,
或者是那些没有接触过个人拍摄过程，甚至可能没有完整阅读剧本的人。他们走进来，以为自己在这里演的是梅尔·布鲁克斯的喜剧，但实际上整部电影一直都是朝着伍迪·艾伦的方向发展的。所以我们需要你把表演基调稍微调低一点，基本上是这样。没错。而这些都是微妙的对话。你不想侮辱一个演员，因为那会带来非常糟糕的效果。
somebody that hasn't been exposed to the personal process or maybe not even read a full script. And they come in and they think they might be doing a Mel Brooks thing here, but actually the whole film has been going the Woody Allen direction. And so we need you to kind of tone it down, basically. Right. And those are delicate conversations. You don't want to insult an actor because then you get really bad stuff.
但我以前做过那种走过去不得不进行一次谈话的情况，我说：嘿，听着，我想确保我的音量没有跟其他人不一样。所以我在做这个包袱，但是……片场的工作人员对我的包袱根本不笑，所以……对，对。只是因为——就像杰伊，从选角角度来说——如果你是一个大、大、大、大明星，比如 A 级（A-plus）国际超级巨星，他们显然不会去试镜什么的，而你选用了他们。
But I've done that before where I've come in and I've like had to talk where I go like, hey, listen, I want to make sure I'm not coming in at a different volume from everybody else. So I'm kind of doing this bit, but this bit, the grips aren't laughing at the bit I'm doing. So, yeah, yeah. Only because like Jay from like, I asked that because from like a casting standpoint, like, if you, if you're a big, big, big, big star, like a plus, you know, mega international superstar and they're not going to obviously audition or anything, and you cast them.
是的，每个人都在猜。这就是你得到的。是的，那就是……这就是我的问题，你知道，你现在在猜。以威廉为例，他有着那种才华，他能够对那种情况做出反应，正如他刚才所说的那样，他能够嗅出苗头并做出调整，这样他既能演同一部电影，
Yeah, everyone's guess. That's what you get. Yeah, that's, and that was my question, is you know, you're guessing now, in Willem's case, he's got the kind of talent where he can, he can be reactive to that, what he was saying, is that he can kind of sniff it out and make adjustments so that he isn't the same movie
又能继续扮演一个让他感到满意的角色版本。你试着去这么做。说到《基督最后的诱惑》（The Last Temptation of Christ），我非常喜欢。你演了耶稣。你演了耶稣基督。我为此做过研究。我演的是一个耶稣基督，而不是上帝耶稣基督。
and still doing a version of the character that's satisfying for him. You try. Well, I'm speaking of the last temptation of Christ, which I loved. You played Jesus. You played Jesus Christ. I was research on that. I played A. Jesus Christ, not Vod Jesus Christ.
你演了一个耶稣，顺便说一句，这不是你第一次演，因为在那之前不久，很多人认为你的角色……化名。上士化名（Sergeant Elias）就是，对吧？一直都有……对，对。这很酷。两者都是极好的机会。
You played A. Jesus and by the way, not your first time because right before that a lot of people thought that your character... Alias. Sergeant Alias was, right? There was always... Yeah, yeah. Which was cool. Both were great opportunities.
顺便说一句，肖恩，你得知道我读过这个采访。我们谈论的另一个采访，关于《化名》、上士化名，他们问你关于耶稣的事，以及与《野战排》的比较，而你说，嗯，我不知道耶稣以前有没有去过丛林里开枪打死人。所以我不知道这个比较是否……我觉得那是个相当不错的回答。
By the way, Sean, you got to know that I read this interview. This other interview we were talking about, Alias, Sergeant Alias, and they asked you about the Jesus thing, the comparison, the platoon, and you were like, well, I don't know if Jesus went in the jungle and shot people up before. So I don't know if that comparison is. I think that's a pretty good answer.
顺便说一下，肖恩，你得知道我看过这个采访。我们刚才讨论的另一个采访，Alias，Sergeant Alias，他们问你关于耶稣的事、那个比较、排里的事，然后你说，嗯，我不知道耶稣以前有没有去过丛林里开枪杀人。所以我不知道这个比较是否合适。我觉得这是一个相当不错的回答。
They both seem like tough shoots. Which set was more uncomfortable? The jungles or the arid desert? Listen, they were very different because of what my role was, but they were both great because they were full on. Both of them were extremely low budget movies. People don't expect that of last temptation of Christ, but that was made for a nickel. And both of them were about as far from Hollywood as you could get in terms of no trailers, no very little makeup, no, you know, you dressed yourself, you showed up and were in the jungle.
Are you showed up? You were in the desert. And they all had modest schedules and modest frills and you just shot away and both were full immersion so that always helps you because if you're in it you can't be out of it. Yeah, you find that more satisfying than when you go and then you go because you have made independent films you've made these these art house pictures with you worked with with some of them. If I read you guys the list of the directors that will have this work, it's mind-blowing career. I mean, so, that, I'm so ambious of all these people
that you've worked with and that they've gotten to work with you. But when you go and then you work on some huge, huge budget film where the money is spent that is just wasted. Like, you could make a movie for their catering budget every day, right? You know what I mean? Yeah, I see that and that bugs me, but I get a let it go because I say, you know, it's not my money and this is how they make these films. And, you know, I like being a part of that too.
And it does things that other movies don't do. Yeah. It gives you the opportunity to make less on a smaller film. You know, I've always had, for the most part, I feel more comfortable when I've got more involvement and not more control, but there's more collaboration. We're in bigger films, not always, but in bigger films, there's a tendency to have lots of cooks
and lots of concerns. And you just accept that, see what it is, and do the best you can and try to have fun. Speaking of big films in that way, and this is like one of the first, I don't know if you guys knew this. Well, I mean, you're barely in because they cut out your character, but you were in, and I didn't know this, you were in heaven's gate, man. Wow. Oh, really? And you shot him in like three months? Yeah.
And I was fired from it as well. No. No. Oh, you were? Yeah. After three months? After three months. Oh, my God.
You know, I was, I was a guy working in the theater and someone said, you should, should audition for this movie because they're looking for ethnic faces. Oh boy. And I remember the audition was, and I wasn't going up for stuff, I was just identified totally as being a downtown theater actor. You know, I had my ambitions, I, you know, when I heard that, I thought, cool, I'm going to check this out. So they asked for a monologue in English and a monologue in another language. I didn't, at that point, I didn't know any other languages.
So I asked a friend who was in town who was flemish to translate in Dutch. Well, you know, I don't know why. It was just, because he was in town. So I did it fanatically. I got the role, but the role was like a nonscripted part. There was a core of people that Chimino was gonna fold in the movie, because the idea was you'd see these people, you'd create a community so in the end, when they all die in this war, you'd feel a connection to it.
Not a bad idea. And it was interesting because, you know, the first day we, like, became a week behind because he kept on inventing things. And it was fun. I enjoyed it. You know, it was really, you were working with great actors. You were, he had just come off the Academy Award. There was a lot of excitement about the movie, the art direction was beautiful, all that. But it got really extreme, as far as, you know, getting dressed and then makeup and sitting in your trailer all day and not shooting for four days. This kind of thing.
Anyway, it became extreme. They saw, the studio saw it was a runway production and the pressure mounted. And I think by three months there was so much tension that Chimino was a little squirrely. And we were in a lighting setup all day. We weren't even going to shoot. We were in full costume in a lighting setup. And you had to raise your hand to go to the toilet like a little kid, you know, but you were there all day on your feet. And to kill time, you know, we talked to each other a little bit not loud, but we talked to each other a little bit, not loud, but we talked to each other. And a woman next to me told me a dirty joke, and I laughed. And Chimino heard my laugh and turned around and said, well, I'm step out. And that was it. No, it's, wow. That's like, I always,
so you're basically doing stand-in, where you're doing your own stand-in work, yeah? Oh, yeah. Because they were lighting the shot. But good with that, you know what? I always do. But it's a very hard thing to do well. It's a real talent to stand there, stared in other actor's face, not say a word, don't play on your phone, stand still,
so that they can like the shot for a half an hour. It's a lot of discipline. I really admire that there is. I always stand in for myself and I must also say, and I'm bragging here, I don't ever bring a phone to that. Really? Wow. Not allowed.
Not allowed. Takes you out. Yeah, I take you out for sure. So Willem, tell me, I have to, I always ask people who come on that, I have a theater background. Do you have a theater nightmare story that we would love? I have tons of them, something that went horribly wrong,
something that you'll never forget. Man, this is the story of the Worcester group. I mean, it was exciting, but we always had lots of problems and then with touring and I think, I'm trying to thank so many, so many. I think we did one burlesque. My partner at the time was the director,
and she, her father died. And we stopped work on a piece and needed to do something light and easy. So we decided to do a dance piece piece which we called a record album interpretation. And we took an old Hawaiian record from the 50s, really coronate, you know, Hawaiian music. And we got some grass skirts and some lays and someone painted a backdrop. And we invented these dances. We just made them up. and we'd do the dances to this music, you know, and between a woman elegantly dressed
with give a little instruction, you know, to give it a cultural context. Well anyway, the gag was to make it stick under our grass skirts. We weren't wearing anything. And also it was two men and a woman, and she was also not wearing anything and bare-breasted. Well, we did this show. It was very popular.
Sure. It was a little chamber piece, but very popular. And at the time, someone said, would you come and do like one number at a party? And they offered us like, I can't remember like a thousand bucks a piece and at that time we're all really poor that was like wow yeah we can do that. So we went to this party you know they had dressed us we got dressed in like the toilet and then we came out without the set
only with the music and with our non costumescostumes. And we did the stance, you know? And they started throwing singles at you. At the end, yeah, people started coming up and saying, okay, let's go, come with me. They thought we were like a stripper, Graham, and then some, not wow. That's his miracle. But did you, Willem, did you, you've been living in Europe for a number of years now?
Yeah, I still keep a place in New York, but yeah. It really depends on work, but where I... Are you in Europe now? Italy. In Italy. That's where you live? Oh, wow. Yeah.
What part? North or South? Rome. Oh. Wow. So then where you live. Oh wow. Yeah. What part? North or South? Rome. Oh wow. So then you know Italian. You speak Italian? Yes, I do better. Yeah. How long have you been living? Not well enough. Everybody gets the six-year-old version of me when I speak Italian. How long you've been living in Rome? Well, to be fair, I've had a place here for 20 years and I'm married on Italian and we've been going back and forth for 20 years. But just lately, I seem to spend more time in Italy because I've been working more abroad, even on American movies. I mean, people shoot a lot outside of the country and those seem to be the movies I end up on.
Yeah. Yeah, well, that makes sense to me, but I don't know why. But also, I guess my question is, and it also, if somebody says to me, Willem the foe lives in Rome, I go, right, that makes sense to me. Of course. And because, and I think that you have this, I don't know, there's something very, you have a progressive sort of sensibility
about you sort of artistically. And I wonder, how do you feel as an American living over there? Do you notice a difference? Do you feel a sense of more calm when you're in Europe versus here? or vice versa? I don't know. I mean, I'm forever a Wisconsin boy, you know, you can't lose that, you know, you can't even if you want to. Except they have they've got to have better cheese in Italy. So yeah, it's a tight fight.
Dude, are you start, are you guys gonna start a war with Wisconsin? What are you doing? No, no, no. Let's stop it right there. I don't know what you got. I'm one of those guys. Where were we? That blue one.
About living in Europe. About living in Europe, though. Listen, I've always spent a lot of time traveling because even with the Wester group, we spent a lot of time traveling, because even with the Wussel Group, we spent a lot of time touring, mostly internationally. So, I'm not even making a stake for, you know, a sensibility or I feel more comfortable. It's just my life.
That's where my family is, you know? I mean, my new family. And I mean, I have son who lives in the States, but, and I'm always happy have son who lives in the States, but and I'm always happy to come back to New York. I love New York, and I'm happy to work in the States. I don't know. I always feel a little bit like an immigrant here,
partly because of the language. But I like that because it's sort of humbling and you know, it keeps you away from yourself. It forces you to always be, you know, be in the place where you're not putting, you're not telling your story or you're not putting yourself forward. You got to hang back, you got to see how people do things and you've got to not be the best at stuff all the time. And you get used to that. And it opens up a different view for you. So I think that helps. So in some ways, I love it because once again, it's like a mask, it's something to hide behind. But also it takes a certain kind of ego pressure off and
you learn how to be an idiot. Like recently I just did something where well anytime I deal with like Italian workmen or something you know they defer to my wife because she speaks so much better than I do and I'm like the idiot. because she speaks so much better than I do. And I'm like the idiot. You know what I mean? And that gives you a different orientation and really helps you to re-know kind of cleanse yourself
you learn how to be an idiot. Like recently I just did something where well anytime I deal with like Italian workmen or something, you know they defer to my wife because she speaks so much better than I do and I'm like the idiot. because she speaks so much better than I do. And I'm like the idiot. You know what I mean? And that gives you a different orientation and really helps you to re-know kind of cleanse yourself
of getting barren down on what you're doing, what your history is, you know, taking, you know, flattery, you know, you take the criticism as well as the flattery, you know, taking, you know, flattery, you know, you take the criticism as well as the flattery, you know, it helps you. It helps you because I don't think that's, that's, uh, naturally our nature. Yeah, folks would fall in all over you in the states. I'm sure you're very, very recognizable in the states. Are you, are you stopped in, in Europe as much as you are in the states? I'm better known internationally than I am. Are you?
Why? In the States. But you make something like Spider-Man movie, and it's so widely seen, that's true. For a lot of people, that's where you get recognized for. Well, your first name is actually William, and Willem was a nickname. Yeah, oh really?
And people are always curious about that, because they think it reveals something, you know? And like there's a time I was interviewed on a TV show, I can't remember, I think it was Jimmy Fallon or something, and this was brought up. And it gets lots of clicks, it gets lots of visits on that YouTube thing. People really are fascinated by that.
They're like, oh, you're busted. You've been telling us, you've got a fake name, you know? It's crazy. It's like the irony is, it was a nickname. And by the time it was time to put my name on a program, I thought, well, I don't feel like William. That sounds a little formal. It makes me sound, it sounds formal in English.
It's not who I am. And Billy, I, or Bill, I haven't used in years, and Willie, forget that, particularly in England, although I do love that name. So I say, okay, I'm Willem DeFoe, you know? So then to choose my birth name then, almost feels like a stage name. Yeah, right, right. Hey, Willem, let's just, sorry, go back to Bobby Proof for a second
because I love, well, at heart, and I love that character. Right, right. And it has one of my favorite scenes in film history actually is when, near the end, when Nick Cage is surrounded by all those guys and he lights his cigarette and he's like, what the fuck do you guys want?
Then they beat him up, right? And it's such a hilarious moment. But I love that. Talk to us a little bit about you're getting involved with that and with David and Bobby Peru. And by the way, it kind of goes back to Jason's point. How the fuck do you come up with that character, Bobby Peru, man? Like that's...
I didn't. I didn't. I mean, it was on the page, as you say. And also, I like that movie a lot. And Bobby Peru is a magical character for me. And there are some beautiful scenes in there. The writing was great, David was cool. And the thing was, I always say often that the best directors really give you a world,
and then you enter that world, and you know what you got to do. Well, and while that hard, it's like, I came, it's like not a big conversation about the costume. It's like, here's your costume Willem, and he gave it to me, you know, and I put it on and it was absolutely right. You know, the writings, language I related to, its placement is perfect. I did very little. And then I talk about this a lot too, but those teeth. When I read it, I just assumed they'd put some funk on my teeth. But when I saw David, he said,
well, we've got to send you to the dentist to make those teeth. And they made these dentures that didn't allow me to close my mouth. So, you know, you're always like this. You're a mouth-cream there. And that makes you immediately like, lascivious, like you're ready to suck on something, you know? Yeah, yeah. And you don't have to do much more.
And that was the key. You know, you're always looking for these triggers. And these triggers either hit something in your imagination or they open you up to something that you didn't know before. And then you go and you ride on that. They grabbed you by the neck, you know. That's not a decision. That's something you invest because it falls into your lap. So there was something magical about Bobby Prue. I mean, I don't want to get too crazy about it. No, please.
That was fun to do. It wasn't a lot of work, not a lot of conversation. Just hit the ground running, and I liked it a lot. Oh, that blows me away. We'll be right back. This episode is brought to you in part by Top Golf. It's golf. It's not golf, it's Topgolf. Here's the deal, you'll get clubs, balls, teas, turf, ball picker, upper, cart thing.
But you also get loud music, giant targets in their, in their giant fairway, giant TVs, in a handcrafted food and beverage menu, put all these things under one roof, got yourself a good time. So consider this, your formal invitation to grab the fam, few friends or some co-workers and come play around. Don't golf? The matter. Yes, golf can be kind of hard, but no one is not good at top golf.
Everyone can play top golf, even if you've never swung a club before and I keep telling this to Sean, the food they're alone should get you there. Because we'll go, we'll hit some bombs, you know, maybe hit them, I don't know, I don't want to get into numbers because I don't want to start getting a lot of feedback from people like, oh, you only hit it 310 or whatever it is, you know, that's what my three would. But the point is, Sean, while I'm doing that, Sean can be on that menu and just, and it'll be on me.
I'm happy to pay for his, which, by the way, is, you know, very generous if you knew how much he would eat at one of these plates, because the food is delicious and also drink. And he could also talk to other people if he wanted to, you know, strangers, because Sean loves strangers. By the way, it reminds me, literally,
all you gotta do is contact Sean for an autograph and he'll make you chicken fingers. And by an autograph, I mean, he wants your autograph, just approach him if you see him in an airport on the street, if you see him in his car. Just be like, hey, Sean, I know that you're pretending you don't wanna talk to me, but here I am. Anyway, Top Golf, it's a good time to go with your friends
and hit some balls and have some laughs and have some great music and have some great food and just hang out. Visit topgolf.com slash smartness to book a bay and come play around. That is topgolf.com slash smartness. I'm not afraid to tell you we get support from Audible. Okay, it's the home of storytelling. Now, I'm not, you know, a great reader.
Okay, I've for a bunch of reasons that I'm not going to bore you with. But so this Audible, these people, they're on to something here. All right, I may not read, but I will listen. Now, you're going to discover thousands of podcasts from popular favorites to exclusive new series. You're going to, you're going to find guided wellness programs with audible. You're going to find theatrical performance is comedy and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities, renowned experts and exciting new voices in audio.
The audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere while you're traveling, working out, walking, doing chores, you decide. All right? Now, for instance, this book, the Suttler Art of Not Giving A Fuck by Mark Manson, this is a potential key to life. It is the, you know, they talk about on the show,
the sexy indifference is an obnoxious term, but it's better said by Mark Manson here, or better heard on Audible. New members can try Audible for 30 days. Visit Audible.com, slash SmartLess, or text SmartLess to 500-500. That's Audible.com slash SmartLess or text smartless to 500 500 that's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartless
and now back to the show. Are you the type of actor that when you're walking around just living your daily life, you're keeping both eyes wide open to absorb certain caricatures or traits of interesting people and kind of put it in your back pocket and just like, I mean, I don't mean it is contrived is that, but more just like, no, listen, I probably was like that when I was younger. But now, I'm just trying so hard to be a better person. Sure, but a better person that that fades into it. Yes, and I don't think that those things are mutually exclusive in that it seems like you are, you love people, you love mankind, you think people are really interesting, and I'm social.
Right. And you're trying to always keep yourself kind of growing and what not. And as you said earlier, you're all all these parts are always a part of you. And so just by expanding you, you're widening your abilities and your spectrum of characters that you can play, the older you get in the question? Yeah, I think, you know, it's like I was at, I was doing a film in London and just the other day, and I went to the tape modern. I had some time off, I thought, what do I do, you know, today and I walked to the tape modern, you know, took me like an hour and a half
where I was staying. And I went there and there was an exhibit up and there was a thing about what's her name? Damn. Alice Neal. I paint my time using the people as evidence. Uh-huh. Yeah. And that was there was something good about that. And I think, you know, we're here as witnesses. We inhabit these things. They aren't us, you know, film television, these things where we come together and make these things, they're so collaborative
that, you know, you just, you just put it out there and it's a reflection of your experience. It's not even an explanation of your experience a lot of time. That's why I get crazy about interpretation sometimes. You know, be there to have it happen. It love to happen, Marcus Oralius, right? So that's what I like. And I do love people because, you know, they're all fighting this struggle that we all have in common. I think, you know, when I feel sweet and really compassionate, I really do believe our job is to walk each other home.
You know, that's what the story is here. So to be fair to you, Jason, your question about do I observe things? I don't like, I'm sorry if I was naughty about that. It was just like, I don't see like me the guy and say, hey, he's got a cool accent. I got to log that. Right, right. I'm taking it on because I'm, as a person, I'm taking him on.
Yeah. And I am, I am him, you know, I'm trying to imagine his life. He's lying him. You're experiencing him. Yeah. And that, I think that I think that's the fountain. That's the fountain. Do you watch what you do?
Some actors, incredibly talented actors, never do watch their films or their dailies or what not. I do, but I don't go back. I mean, I've watched them when they come out, you know, like, you know, when you have to do press for something. And you're also curious how things turned out, you know, because a lot of times you're not involved in the post. Yeah, exactly. And that was going to be my follow-up.
Sometimes you are. You give such a beautiful contribution to every film that you do. Is there, I won't ask you what your favorite film is or your favorite part is, but I will ask you which film that you've done do you feel that your contribution happened to slot in once you saw the finished product. A lot of the execution you weren't there for, as the director finished this thing up later, that you were most excited about like, oh, that ended up fitting in a really satisfying way. To me as an audience member.
That's hard, because, yeah, it's a good question, but that's hard only because when I see the movie that I'm in, I can't watch it. I mean, I do watch it, but it's like watching a home movie. It's an association of making the movie. It always happens to me. It's very rare. I will say there are exceptions.
Like I recently saw poor things, this Yorgos Lentham movie. That isn't out yet. What a great filmmaker he is. And that's one of the few times I saw the movie. And maybe it's because I have prosthetics and all that, where I didn't see myself. And I didn't remember because there's a lot of fantastical stuff in post on. And that was pretty interesting to watch this movie, which I love, and to feel like I was watching someone else. That's quite rare. Normally, when I watch, I say, oh, God, I remember that day. So, and so we had a fight or that lunch was terrible.
Or, you know, we ran really late that night. Or, you know, that day player, K-Man, and I had a nervous breakdown. You know, these are the things you remember. Yeah, of course. Yeah. I would imagine Spider-Man has the same type of thing where you can't really see what's going on around you
because it comes in later. Is there a satisfaction in seeing that? Oh, that's cool. I was pretending to see that and they made me not a liar by making that monster super big and matched my reaction. It's true. You know. It's true.
Yeah. That's a special. It's weird that you say that because don't you guys do that too when you watch something you go like, oh, I remember I had a head cold that day and I could barely, I was blowing my nose between takes. And I remember doing this thing where this is about 10 years ago, I was doing one of those Ninja Turtle movies and we had, I had the runs, I had like a stomach virus. And the director says, yeah, great, I've never told this story. And the director says, yeah, great. I've never told this to and the director says, we're doing reshoots. And I had to run with Megan Fox. We had to run across this parking lot. And the guys like, okay, you're going to jump out of the
thing and you guys got to run across the parking lot. And I said, and I go, man, I'm not running anywhere. I said, if I'm in my pants, I said, I can barely, and we both had it. And I said, if I move from this thing, it's, it's, it's over. I'm back on the trees on these pants. Yeah. Do we need quadruples on the pants here, dude? So I go, I can get out of the van and I can talk here and I can maybe slowly walk and you got to fucking cover me. You can't even get a wide because you can't see how I'm walking. Otherwise, you're going to know that I'm, you know what I mean? Yeah, but those are the things I remember when I watch it I go. Oh, that was when I had the runs diarrhea My advice always keep a bucket close by nice
I'd like to stay on the set Maybe you can cut that out. Get loose. Get loose. Get loose. By the way, I love it. And you know, Will and we have a mutual friend who's a big friend of the podcast who said, I said, you know, he's like, you got to get Will and he's Bradley.
Oh, Bradley, sure. We had a good time. And I kept in touch with him and we've seen each other since and he's always said something interesting to say or interesting to show where he loves you He loves you, man. Oh, we had a good time and yeah, I enjoy seeing him. What did you what did you? You made this you made a few movies with Wes Anderson, right? And now you're in this asteroid city But really a cameo. I mean, that's not an apology. It's just a fact. Yeah, okay.
And explanation, an explanation, if you will. But what is that relationship with, with notwithstanding just being a cameo, with Wes Anderson in his films and. You know, I it started my first film. I think I've made five with him and you know, in varying degrees of. You know, some are bigger roles, some are cameos, but it started with life aquatic. Yeah, and that actually is what brought me to Rome because I met my wife on that shoot. Oh wow. In Rome. So that kind of changed my life. But life aquatic was so much fun. And it was
basically kind of like heaven's gate in the fact that it was a role that was barely scripted. Well it was scripted, but he kept on sliding things, me enter things, and then we kind of inventing stuff. And that was really, really fun. And I like life aquatic a lot. It's me too. I like life aquatic. It's kind of slippery for a long, long, for a lot of the movie. But at the end, surprisingly, it has an emotional effect.
I think that sneaks up on you, and I love when you're able to do that in a movie. Something where you think, ah, this is fun, it's goofy, you know, you're kind of following it, and then it slaps you across the face. Or really, you know, lets you know what all that led up to.
That's very cool. So I worked with Mon Life Aquatic, you know, all that led up to. That's very cool. So I worked with him on life aquatic, you know, just to dork him. So when you have a good thing, you know, whether it's Robert Eggers or Abel Farah or Paul Shader, when you have a good thing, you know, at the end. I just worked with Tim Burton, you know,
and you say, hey, that was fun. Let's do it again and call you again. Do you have, we talk about this all the time, the three of us do, and on the show and stuff. Do you have like goals in mind, when I mean goals, I mean stuff that you go, like, I wanna go and do something like this. I wanna work on a project like this,
or not so much. No, huh? No, you know, and why don't I say directors are very important? Because it's probably why I'm not a director, okay? And that is I like going towards something. I don't like having an idea and then I want to accomplish it, you know? I like being put in a situation and I have to flirt, punch, kick, slide my way out of it.
Because I think for me, that suits me. I mean, I like doing that. But if you say, oh, you know, I'd really like to play a union organizer. I'd really like to play Joe Stalin. I'd really like to play, you know, Reverend Moan or something. You know, it kind of finished completely itself because you have this idea and it's like your idea. I suppose you could pursue it and it would change. But I'd rather, I really like attaching myself
因为我觉得对我来说，这很适合我。我的意思是，我喜欢这么做。但如果你说，哦，你知道，我真的很想演一个工会组织者。我真的很想演约瑟夫·斯大林。我真的很想演，你知道，莫恩牧师或类似的角色。你知道，这就完全结束了，因为你有这个想法，这就像是你的想法。我想你可以去追求它，它会改变。但我宁愿，我真的很喜欢把自己
to someone else's idea. And then it's like somehow they take the responsibility and you can be irresponsible as an actor. You're terrifically responsible to performing because you wanna be there, anything else just doesn't work. It's an opportunity. It's a blessing to be able to be given this situation where you have this super supercharged consciousness you know because when you're performing in the best of situations you're more alive than you are in life
附着在别人的想法上。然后就好像他们承担了责任，而作为演员你可以不用负责。你对表演负有极大的责任，因为你想去那里，其他任何事情都行不通。这是一个机会。能够被赋予这种状态是一种福气，在这种状态下你拥有超级充沛的意识，你知道，因为当你处于最佳状态进行表演时，你比生活中
sometimes. It's sad but you know what I'm talking about. All of you know what I'm talking about. No, of course. So you look for those situations and to get those situations, I don't think you can set yourself up. You've got to be surprised and you've got to work from a place of not knowing initially, and then you go towards something, and then you learn towards something and then you learn something and that changes how you think and that that change of thinking opens your door to like be born as a no person and then you apply that energy, that kind of mind-blowing
有时更加充满活力。这很可悲，但你知道我在说什么。你们所有人都知道我在说什么。不，当然。所以你会寻找那些情况，为了得到那些情况，我不认为你能刻意去安排。你必须感到惊讶，你必须从最初的一无所知开始工作，然后你朝着某个方向前进，然后你朝着某个方向学习，然后你学到了一些东西，这改变了你的想法，这种思维的改变为你打开了一扇门，就像以一个一无所知的人的身份诞生，然后你把那种能量，那种令人震撼的
noonness to what you're doing and if all the stars align and if everything's correct and you don't get distracted or you don't shoot yourself in the floor or you don't get fully yourself and all these little temptations and things to fuck you up, then you get something, you know? And is it something to sell? Is it something that people love? You don't know, but I always trust that I'm not a Martian. So on somewhere, if I'm something's happening to me and it's transparent enough that someone can identify with it or can go with me on that trip, you know? Then it's worth doing.
纯真应用到你正在做的事情上，如果所有的星星都排列在一起，如果一切都正确，你没有分心，或者你没有自己给自己使绊子，或者你没有完全沉浸在自己里，以及所有这些小诱惑和毁掉你的事情，那么你就会有所收获，你知道吗？这东西能卖吗？这是人们喜欢的东西吗？你不知道，但我总是相信我不是火星人。所以在某种程度上，如果有什么事情发生在我身上，而且它足够透明，以至于别人能够感同身受，或者能跟我一起经历那段旅程，你知道吗？那么这就值得去做。
It's worth doing. Sean, you can't believe the disappointment on Sean's face when he found out you weren't a Martian. Because he just loves Sean's life. He loves outer space. Well, when you're not doing your work, your acting work, what is your next favorite thing to do? Do you have a hobby that you're super passionate about?
这很值得去做。肖恩，当你发现你不是火星人时，肖恩脸上的失望简直无法形容。因为他太热爱肖恩的生活了。他热爱外太空。好吧，当你不做工作，不做你的演艺工作时，你最喜欢做的事情是什么？你有什么超级热爱的爱好吗？
I don't have hobbies. I feel like I'm always preparing for something. I try to be. I have certain disciplines that I do daily, you know? And also, I have a farm now. So, I never had animals or pets or anything like that. But now I have lots of animals and I grow my own food. So that's so true. Wow. So that's a big deal. So it marries it marries that kind of the simple tasks of of doing like chores and and cultivating things and eating out of your own place. Yeah. Are you, is that in Italy that you're doing that? Yeah, yeah. But the animals are a big deal. And we don't eat them because I'm basically a vegetarian. And we keep them.
我没有什么爱好。我觉得我好像总是在为某事做准备。我尽量这样做。我有一些每天都在做的清规戒律，你知道吗？而且，我现在有一个农场。所以，我以前从来没有养过动物、宠物或类似的东西。但现在我有很多动物，而且我自己种食物。所以这是真的。哇。所以这是一件大事。所以它把那种做家务、耕种土地以及吃自己种的东西的简单任务结合在了一起。
And sometimes I check myself on this. This is really correct. But we try to give them a good life. And we try to enjoy them. And they're a beautiful reminder, you know, they connect you to nature. And when you can be connected to nature, I think you can be connected to things beyond this life. Yeah. Yeah. Amen. What's your favorite thing to do with the with the animals? Are you milking cows? Are you grabbing eggs from chickens? I don't milk cows.
是的。你是在意大利做这件事吗？是的，是的。但动物是一件大事。我们不吃它们，因为我基本上是个素食主义者。我们养着它们。有时我会反思自己这一点。这真的很正确。但我们努力给它们一个美好的生活。我们努力享受与它们在一起的时光。它们是一个美丽的提醒，你知道的，它们把你和自然连接起来。当你能与自然连接时，我想你就能与超越这个生命的事物连接。
How are you milking cows? Are you grabbing eggs from chickens? I don't milk cows. I do take care of chickens. I've got alpacas, and they're the sweetest animals in the world. But it's challenging because they're a little delicate. Like today, I was nursing one who was sick, and I was very... I worry more about these animals, sounds messed up, and this is why I never had animals before, and I thought people that were so attached to their animals were sick. But I worry so much about them. You know, I probably worry about them more than I did about my children, because they can't talk to you. Right. And you know, when you see that animal suffering and you look in their eyes, you. Right. And you know, when you see that animal suffering and you look in their eyes,
是的。是的。太棒了。你和动物在一起最喜欢做的事是什么？你在挤牛奶吗？你在从鸡窝里抓鸡蛋吗？我不挤牛奶。你怎么挤牛奶？你在从鸡窝里抓鸡蛋吗？我不挤牛奶。我确实照顾鸡。我有羊驼，它们是世界上最温顺的动物。但这也很有挑战性，因为它们有点娇贵。就像今天，我在照顾一个生病的羊驼，我非常……我为这些动物操的心，听起来可能有点毛病，这也是我以前从来不养动物的原因，而且我以前觉得那些对动物过于依恋的人脑子有病。但我太为它们操心了。
and you've got a relationship with them there, you know, you feed them, you put them in when the weather's loud so you take them out, you know, in the morning, you've got a relationship. They're dependent on you, but it's not like, you know, a sloppy dog that just gives you love unconditionally. These like these alpacas are very regal and they're they're very sensitive and they're gorgeous. But sometimes I wonder, is this, you know, maybe they should just be in the wild. But I try to give them a good life. Could be hostile out there though. That's true. That's true. And it can be hostile here. We've got, we've got wolves. We've got Foxes. We've got lots of boars. You know stuff happens the other day. Fox took five of my chickens. I'm gonna work with these two boars every day. Hey listen.
你知道的，我为它们操的心可能比为我自己的孩子操的心还多，因为它们不会跟你说话。对吧。你知道的，当你看到那只动物在受苦，当你看着它们的眼睛，你。对吧。你知道的，当你看到那只动物在受苦，当你看着它们的眼睛，你和它们之间有了一种联系，你知道的，你喂它们，天气吵闹时把它们弄进来，早上带它们出去，你知道的，你们有一种联系。它们依赖你，但这不像，你知道的，那种无条件给你热情的一只傻狗。像这些羊驼非常高贵，它们非常敏感，而且它们很华丽。但有时我想，这，你知道的，也许它们本该待在野外。但我尽量给它们一个美好的生活。
I spelled a little differently. Willem, I know, Willem. You know, I've never told anybody about the farm. I've really laid low on that. So I like the way you speak about it. It sounds wonderful. It doesn't sound like it's in Braggie or anything. Okay. No, it's awesome. Well, what I was going to say was,
不过外面可能会有危险。确实如此。确实如此。这里也可能有危险。我们有，我们有狼。我们有狐狸。我们有成群的野猪。你知道事情总会发生，前几天，一只狐狸抓走了我的五只鸡。我每天都要和这两只野猪打交道。嘿，听着。我拼写的方式有点不同。威廉，我知道，威廉。你知道，我从来没跟任何人提起过这个农场。我一直在这方面保持低调。所以我喜欢你谈论它的方式。听起来棒极了。听起来一点也不像是在吹牛什么的。
and I was going to say this earlier, but it really came out in that thing as, I like the way that you talk about, it's kind of like the way that you talk about working on something or a character or the way you break it down or not break it down or just allow yourself to me. It's kind of like that's your lesson that you bring to your life. You seem like you're really honest with yourself about or you're hold yourself accountable
好吧。不，这太棒了。嗯，我要说的是，我本来想早点说这个的，但它真的在那件事中表现出来了，我喜欢你谈论的方式，这有点像你谈论为某事或某个角色工作的方式，或者你剖析它或不剖析它，或者只是让自己去感受的方式。这有点像你带给自己生活的教训。你看起来对自己真的很诚实，或者你经常对自己负责，从你谈论它的方式来看。我喜欢那样。我对此有共鸣。我喜欢对自己诚实这种想法。
often, the way that you talk about it. And I like that. I respond to that. I like that idea of being honest with you. Well, hang on. I got a guess. I know we're almost finished, but hang on. I hope it's not a paca.
好吧，等一下。我有个猜测。我知道我们快结束了，但等一下。我希望那不是羊驼。请说实话。嘿，泰尔。你想看一只漂亮的狗吗？就一会儿。
Please be honest. Hey, tail. You want to see a beautiful dog? Just real quick. Yeah, I love this dog. Yeah. Can you see him? Tail. Oh, wow.
对，我喜欢这只狗。对。你能看到他吗？泰尔。哦，哇。他是一只退役的灵缇犬。别吃那个。他是一只退役的灵缇犬。他刚来的时候，宝贝。他是一只退役的灵缇犬。他刚来的时候，宝贝。他是一只可爱的狗。你知道人们长得像他们的狗吗？嗯-嗯。是的。
He's a rescue Greyhound. Don't be eating that. He's a rescue Greyhound for the track. He finished coming of, baby. He's a rescue Greyhound for the track. He finished coming up, baby. He's a sweet dog. You know how people look like their dogs? Uh-huh. Yeah.
哦，他太漂亮了。威廉，把你的摄像头稍微往下调一点，这样我们能看清这只狗一点。那只狗叫什么名字？泰尔。就像，T-E-O。就像，对不起，天哪。这只狗看起来非常平静。
Oh, he's so beautiful. Tell your camera down a little bit, well, I'm so we can see the dog a little bit. What's that dog's name? Tail. Like, T-E-O. Like, excuse me, God. The dog seems very serene.
啊，他刚来的时候过得很苦。你知道，显然他们在赛道上对它们不是很好，因为最主要的是它们必须奔跑、奔跑、奔跑、奔跑、奔跑。现在他，它们其实就像猫一样。它们睡很多觉。当它们行动时，它们会行动，但大多数时候，而且它们非常，它们非常超然。它们的时间。而且它们非常，它们非常超然。
Ah, he's had a tough life when he arrived. You know, obviously they don't treat them so well at the track because the bottom line is they've got to run, run, run, run, run. And now he's, they're like cats, really. They sleep a lot. When they go, they go, but most of the time, and they're very, they're very looph. They time. And they're very, they're very loof.
它们一点也不邋遢，你知道的，它们非常高贵。哇。不管怎样。伙计，我告诉你，我告诉你，威廉，我们可以，我简直可以跟你聊。我越跟你聊，就越想跟你聊。我一直是你的超级粉丝，这么久以来都是。我只是，我喜欢你做的一切。
They aren't sloppy, you know, they're very regal. Wow. Anyway. Man, I tell you, I tell you what, Willem, we could, I can just talk to you. The more I talk to you, the more I want to talk to you. I've been a, I've been a such a fan of yours for so long. And I just, I love everything you do.
就像，我可以一直这样做下去。而且你太真实了。而且，我只是喜欢你做的一切，并且继续这样做。你太真实了。除了感谢你抽出时间做这件事并花时间陪伴我们之外，我无话可说。是的，当然。我希望，是的，我希望谈话听起来轻松而温暖。就像这是一次很棒的对话。是的。
Like, I can just keep doing it. And you're so authentic. And, just I love everything you do and just keep doing it. And you're so authentic. And I'm nothing to say other than just thank you for doing this and spending this time with us. Yeah, sure. I hope, yeah, I hope it comes off kind of easy and warm. Like it was a great conversation. Yeah.
当你，当你再次来到美国时，我们将交流更多关于戏剧的故事。好的。我想我九月份会去那里，因为我们要为即将上映的《可怜的东西》做一些宣传，这部电影，我等不及要看了。我等不及要看了。
When you come when you come to the States again, we'll swap more theater stories. All right. I think I'm going to be there in September because we're going to do some promotion for this poor things that comes out, which is, I can't wait to see that. I can't wait to see that.
他真是一个伟大的导演。他太棒了。从那以后我又和他合作了一次。哦，是的。另一部电影，是的，叫《And》。这很有趣，因为我们在新奥尔良拍摄，蜘蛛侠的粉丝群会走过来问，嘿，你们在这里做什么？
He's such a great director. He's fantastic. And I worked with him a second time since. Oh, yeah. Another film, yeah, called And. And that was funny because we were shooting in New Orleans and like the Spider-Man crowd would come up and say, hey, what are you doing here?
然后我会说，我在拍电影。他们会说，真的吗，叫什么名字？假设，他们假设也许我每五年才拍一部电影，而且是蜘蛛侠。对，对。所以他们会问，叫什么名字？我说，And，然后他们会说，对，对，但到底叫什么名字？对，没错。
And I'd say, I'm making a film. And they'd say, yeah, what's it called? Assuming, they assume maybe I only make a film every five years in it's Spider-Man. Right, right. So they're like, what's it called? And I say, and, and they're like, yeah, yeah, but what's it called? Yeah, exactly.
然后他们会说，不，没有其他问题。就这个。这没完没了地进行下去。所以最后，我学会了，你知道的，是的，我在这里拍一部电影。叫什么名字？无题。对，对。这是这里的电影。叫什么名字？无题。对
And they're like, no, no other questions. Just that. This goes on and on and on. So finally, I learned, you know, yeah, I'm shooting a film here. What's it called? Untitled. Yeah, yeah. This is film here. What's it called? Untitled. Yeah
伙计，好吧，再次感谢威廉，这真是个巨大的荣幸，能和你交谈真是一大快事。很高兴和你交谈。我听了你的几个播客，我真的很喜欢。嗯，谢谢。我们很喜欢你。是的，所以继续保持出色的工作，继续保持你出色的工作。好的。谢谢。好吧，谢谢你，老兄。太酷了。是的，谢谢。谢谢你，老兄。太酷了。是的。再见。再见。哇。哇。是的，那真是一个非常充实饱满的嘉宾啊。
Man, well again, thank you Will and what an honor and what would it treat to talk to you good nice nice talking to you And I listen to a couple of your podcasts and I really enjoyed it. Well, thanks. We enjoyed you Yeah, so keep up the good work and keep up your good work. Okay. Thanks. Well, thank you, buddy Cool. Yeah, thanks. Thank you, buddy. Cool. Yeah. Bye. Bye. Wow. Wow. Yeah, that's a nice, a nice full person guest there.
是的，一个非常充实饱满的人。我所有的感受，尤其是在最后那里。我开始意识到，当我们被赛道犬泰尔打断时。但抛开所有玩笑不谈，威廉就是那种看起来如此真实的人，听他谈论他的生活。我要说的是，
Yeah, nice full person. Everything I was really especially at the end there. I started to realize that like when we he were interrupted by Theo, the track dog. But all jokes aside, Willem is just one of those guys who just seems so authentic and hearing him talk about his life. And what I was gonna say is like,
他在谈论自己的事情时很真实，但同时也让人觉得他一直在探索或者坦诚地面对自己作为一个人的身份。是的。并且有点在对自己负责。你们有这种感觉吗？是的，当然。是的，而且感觉我们的行业、我们的城市、
he's authentic in talking about his thing, but he's also just feels like he's constantly searching for or being honest about who he is as a person. Yeah. And kind of holding himself accountable. Did you guys get that sense at all? Yeah, for sure. Yeah, and it seems like a lot about our business, our city,
甚至我们的国家。这与他正在追求的真实之旅有点格格不入。是的。这也与他谋生的职业背道而驰，他的职业是假装成另一个人。所以我的意思是，如果我们还要再讨论一个小时，我会问他，你知道的，比如，他是否为此挣扎过，关于努力对自己保持真实，
our country even. It's like a little bit at odds with the journey that he's on about authenticity. Yeah. And which kind of runs also counter to what he does for a living, which is pretending to be someone else. So I mean, if we're going to do another hour on that, I would have asked him, you know, like, it does he battle with that about trying to really be true to himself
并真正参与其中、保持开放和真实。然而他的职业却是令人信服地扮演一个完全不是自己的人。还有很有趣的是，是的，住在意大利、洛杉矶和纽约，就像无论我在哪里我都做不到。我不得不像，你什么意思你做不到？你正在做着呢。不，但我不能就这样去另一个国家生活并对此感到安然，然后又回到这里。
and really participate and be open and authentic. And yet his profession is convincingly being somebody completely other than himself. And also interesting like, yeah, living Italy and New York and Los Angeles, like wherever I couldn't do it. I have to like, what do you mean you couldn't do it? You're doing it. No, but I can't like just go living in another country and be okay with that and then come back here.
你是上还是叹气，而不是，一个叉子。你是上还是叹气？我不是叉子。你是上还是叹气？你是上还是叹气？我要去德尔莫纳科餐厅，那边那个市场叫什么名字？全食超市旁边？那太难了。
You're up or you sighed instead of, a fork. You're up or you sighed? I'm not a fork. You're up or you sighed. You're up or you sighed. I'm going to go to Del Monaco's and what's the name of that market over there? Instead of whole foods? That's tough.
是的，也许伙计们，也许当你们来这里的时候，你们可以。你来到这个城市我们可以顺便。再见。再见。微笑。我们可以顺便。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。
Yeah, maybe guys, maybe when you come here, you can. You come to the city we can stop. Bye. Bye. Smile. we can stop. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾尔夫和贝内特·巴尔伯科手工制作。[♪ 片尾音乐播放 [♪ SmartLess。本集录制于6月29日。我们的下一集将在四周内发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barberco. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Smart, less. This episode was recorded on June 29th. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music,
或者通过在苹果播客或Wondery App上订阅Wondery Plus来提前收听无广告版。对于新泽西州南部的父母来说，这绝对是他们的噩梦。搜寻工作正在寻找一名自昨天下午以来失踪的11岁开普梅县男孩。到目前为止，搜寻人员只在他的家附近找到了一只他的左运动鞋。很难想象失去一个亲人，一个妻子，一个丈夫，一个孩子。对许多人来说，这是他们最大的恐惧。阿玛丽莎·琼斯，《消失的人》的主持人，这个播客讲述了那些经常被忽视
or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondery Plus wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon music, or early and ad-free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. It is every parent's nightmare when folding in South Jersey. The search is on for an 11-year-old Kate May County boy missing since yesterday afternoon. So far, searchers have found only his left sneaker near his home. It's hard to imagine losing a loved one, a wife, a husband, a child. For many, it's their biggest fear. Amarissa Jones, host of The Vanished, a podcast that tells the stories of often overlooked
且悬而未决的失踪人员案件的故事。每周，我都会深入调查一个新案件，分享他们神秘失踪的细节，包括对家属、朋友、执法人员甚至嫌疑人的采访，以期揭露真相。我很自豪地宣布，这个播客已经协助破获了多起逮捕行动。对我来说，重要的是记住头条新闻背后的那个人，并帮助家属找到他们失踪的亲人，或者至少获得一种心灵的平静。在任何你获取播客的地方关注《消失的人》。你可以在亚马逊音乐或Wondery App上收听无广告版。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。
and unsolved missing persons' cases. Every week, I dive into a new case, sharing the details of their mysterious disappearance, including interviews with family, friends, law enforcement, and even suspects in an effort to reveal the truth. And I'm proud to say that this podcast has aided in a number of arrests. It's important to me to remember the human behind the headline and help family members find their vanished loved one, or at least a sense of peace. Follow the vanished wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen ad-free on Amazon Music or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及未破的失踪人口案件。每周，我都会深入探讨一个新案件，分享他们神秘失踪的细节，包括对家人、朋友、执法人员甚至嫌疑人的采访，以期揭示真相。我很自豪地说，这个播客已经协助破获了好几起案件。对我来说，记住头条新闻背后的活生生的人，帮助家属找到他们失踪的亲人，或者至少找到一丝内心的平静，是非常重要的。在您获取播客的任何地方关注 The Vanished。您可以在 Amazon Music 或 Wondery 应用程序上收听无广告版本。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。